hey there everyone I'm Walter Binet
dziak I'm Heather ruse and I'm Inon and
this is top five last week we took a
look at the best Muppets but not all of
these lovable characters are so lovable
with any property that's been around as
long as the Muppets it's inevitable that
not every character is going to be a
Kermit the Frog or Fozzie Bear plenty of
experiments with new Muppets haven't
always wielded phenomenal results over
the years some of them have just missed
the mark while others are acquired
tastes most people love the Muppets and
all their quirky wacky personalities
however when looking back a few of these
characters don't exactly gel with the
quality put out by this franchise during
its sixth decade long run but which are
the weakest of the bunch these are the
top 5 worst Muppets number 5 Gorgon heap
I sure hope you think eating Muppets is
funny we can't talk about Gorgon heap
without mentioning his predecessor big V
big V was a part of one of the Muppets
most successful and trademark early
sketches the glowworm in the sketch
Kermit sits on a wall and eats a couple
worms that crawl close to him when he
tries to eat a third worm Kermit finds
out that it's actually a long-nosed
connected to a giant monster that
monster was big v who always ate Kermit
at the end of the bit it's a classic
sketch definitely amusing and as I said
a staple skit for the Muppets early on
when the Muppet Show started in 1976 big
V was replaced by a similar monster
called Gorgon Heath Gorgon was pretty
much similar in every way sometimes he
appeared as a full-body muppet meaning
he was more of a costume with a
puppeteer inside and other times as a
live hand Muppet like Fozzie Bear or the
Swedish Chef
he was made a bit less threatening
looking than big V and had
interchangeable horns and ears that
sometimes appeared on his head
the thing about Gorgon heap was just
wasn't very funny I mean you can only
take the eating everything bit so far it
worked in the glowworm sketch because it
was designed that way but making that
characteristic bigger for more
complicated scenes didn't work very well
the fact that his gimmick was eating the
other Muppets also doesn't hold up great
he devoured all our favorites as we were
left
shocked at home wondering if they were
dead for good at least did a little kid
version of me sometimes was I don't want
to see Kermit Rolfe or even Miss Piggy
be consumed by this monstrosity over and
over the glowworm sketch is one thing
but most of his parts on the show
weren't terribly clever and lacked the
enjoyment of the more popular bits
number four Pepe the king prawn next up
is a small fry okay this might be
controversial since a lot of people are
fond of this particular crustacean but
beyond his humor relying a lot on
miscommunications and bad puns he's
repeating of okay at the end of
everything was grating enough to make
our list he is almost as full of himself
as Miss Piggy which is not a simple feat
and hits on anyone with a pulse you just
let me know if I press too hard okay or
not hard enough I'm just reading the
copy no that's not the copy right eyes
up then I'm looking at your legs you
Sharon how'd you like to meet me at the
whoopsy bean peppe's gravely muttering
is more some than outright bad but it's
only made worse when his popsicle stick
friend topo sticky joins in with its
high-pitched tone his large mouth in
comparison to his tiny head and wild
hair is funny but better achieved by
other puppets also that one tooth makes
it look like there's a speck of food on
his lip and I will never unsee it cup a
is a hand and rod puppet and as a prawn
he has multiple arms this gives the
puppeteers extra limbs to work with but
we usually only see the two upper arms
like any other Muppet while the rest are
sewn in pockets or kept out of frame
it's a wasted opportunity since any
other personality in this form could do
those added appendages justice can you
imagine
animal with an extra pair of hands there
are moments his limbs are all in motion
and it's the most animated he gets but
it's almost bordering as breaking
character to get him to that point in
the end he's small and mostly harmless
but whatever you do just don't call him
a shrimp number three
Clifford if you had to choose one Muppet
to take over the mantle of hosting a
Muppet Show who would you choose it
would be Clifford Wright who
Clifford is a pinkish humanoid catfish
Muppet he was first introduced to
audiences on the Jim Henson Tower there
he was portrayed as a laid-back cool guy
who always wore sunglasses had
dreadlocks and played the bass doesn't
seem too bad right sure if that's where
Clifford's Muffit journey ended he
wouldn't be on this list but in 1996 a
new muppet show began airing on ABC it
was called Muppets tonight and much to
everyone's shock Kermit was not the host
he was now the station manager
Kermit asks the Muppets who wants to be
the new host everyone else runs out
except Clifford who was too busy talking
to his girlfriend on the phone to notice
what was happening so Kermit just hires
him to make matters worse Clifford's
personality was toned down his signature
sunglasses were replaced with realize he
wore more appropriate clothing to be a
host he became boring and forgettable he
was like any generic late-night host
later he returned for a couple of Muffet
movies with his old personality in
sunglasses but the damage had been done
he will always be remembered as a lame
host who had the awful task of trying to
fill Kermit's shoes number two
Robbin the Frog like many unmarried
adult men and TV Kermit had a nephew
that occasionally hung out with him
Robin was mainly annoying and small as
he loved to remind the audience
constantly I understand that he was
supposed to be the child's voice and
point of view on the show but couldn't
he be less irritating he had one bit
talking about how small he was he's
saying adorable little songs and was
always honest and innocent to make sure
you knew he was lovable and cute
it was grating every time he was on
screen I just wanted to punt his small
Muppet body he wasn't funny or
interesting just naive the Muppets were
supposed to be edgy and sarcastic at
least when the show first premiered
Robin didn't fit in with this idea or
any of the other Muppets really too
childlike too sincere and too much and
the number one worst Muppet is Waldo see
graphic what makes a muppet am up a
handcrafted design a well-thought-out
comedic character has a super obnoxious
animal clown computer graphic count
officially yes
Waldo see graphic is literally that he's
technically a muppet but not at all in
the traditional sense he takes some
explaining
Waldo first appeared in the Jim Henson
hour in 1989 he was a part of the Muppet
television segments where he served as
the show's demo graphics expert perhaps
what he's most known for though is his
appearance in the Disney World theme
park attraction Muppet vision 3d in the
show he's created by dr. Bunsen honeydew
and is constantly trying to escape the
screen he's portrayed as very energetic
and way over-the-top
often bouncing around the picture of the
entire time he was seen he even
transforms himself into mickey mouse at
the end of the program while those
off-putting personality and strange
concept begged him for our number1 spot
he hasn't been seen in a Muppet
production since the Disney World show
while the idea of a computer animated
Muppet interacting with live-action
counterparts didn't really land in the
late 80s or early 90s it is an
interesting notion on the Jim Henson our
episode secrets of
the Muppets Henson gave us a behind the
scenes look at Waldo's and her workings
this character's purpose was to be
puppeteered live with an early motion
capture puppet contraption the image was
rendered later for higher resolution but
the technology just wasn't quite there
yet
this of course calls to mind motion
capture performances that have gotten
very sophisticated in recent years the
only difference here was that Waldo was
still controlled by a puppeteer instead
of a full body performer
is this something Henson would have
developed more if he was able to
continue his work into the 1990s we'll
never know but it is fascinating to
think about waldo may be our worst
muppet but the technology that created
him in combination with the innovative
genius of jim henson could have given us
something truly unprecedented this week
on my personal channel my old friend
Brian Porter joins me to review the DC
animated movie Batman Gotham by Gaslight
that and much more content is available
on the awesome Walter YouTube channel
right now we want to hear what you guys
think who's your least favorite Muppet
what do you want to see us cover next on
the show leave a comment and let us know
to keep in touch you can like my
Facebook page or follow along on Twitter
and you can find me on Facebook Twitter
or Instagram and you can find me on
Instagram Twitter or twitch where I
stream on Wednesday nights
we'll catch you right back here next
week with a brand new episode of top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
someday we'll find it The Rainbow
Connection the lovers the dreamers in me
will you stop it with the carbon
impression sorry I just really love that
song oh uh I'm sorry I saw your Walter
well his voice does sound a lot like
Hermes I don't sound like Kermit
you